what we're gonna talk about the bridges
of königsberg that is the heading over
there
what we're going to talk about is this
see for a little bit so this is a really
old picture as you can probably tell you
can see the title up there at the top
there's just to be a prussian city I
don't know how many who studies in
history here anyone are they is are you
guys doing like Bismarck in that kind of
thing or not really yeah it's all
different news quite as him grab a seat
quickly please
so Prussia was an ancient area sort of
right in the middle of Europe really but
it got sort of subsumed by Russia and so
this actually is now called Kaliningrad
so same place different name okay now
this city is really famous and we're
going to study at this period for a few
particular reasons that I'll tell you
about later but for now I just want to
actually show you why this city is
interesting what you've got is all of
these buildings and if you squint hard
you'll see there's like waterways
through here do you see them can you
make them out I know it's black and
white it's not that easy and then these
waterways many of them have bridges over
them do you see that right now I've got
because I thought it was pretty hard to
see I've just redrawn this right and
what I've highlighted is where the water
goes so you kind of have like this
island good morning
these are Island sort of areas in the
middle and then you've got these one two
three four five six seven bridges ok the
bridges of königsberg okay now what
people wondered about for a long time
for decades when this city was born was
just a really silly random playful
question no particular like problem they
were trying to solve they were just
interested in this question that I'm
going to pose to all of you which is can
all of these bridges be crossed without
ever having to cross a bridge twice
right you know so that again so can all
of the bridges all seven of them can
they be crossed without ever having to
set foot on any of these bridges twice
now we've been in this topic of networks
for a little while now and so you guys
know most of this information that's in
the map is actually irrelevant like all
of these buildings and stuff we don't
care about those there's an unemployment
right I'm even exactly where the bridges
are unimportant so there are lots of
like kind of more diagrammatically
representative ones this is not really
what the city looks like but it's got
all the same information on a DC key
account the bridges one two three
four or five six and in the seventh one
is in the middle so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna give you guys one of these I
highly advise you to use a pencil for
this and I want you to see if you can
solve this puzzle can you cross all the
bridges go ahead how are you going
has anyone managed to yellow a through
so this is like for such a simple
diagram this is deceptively difficult
and now you're saying to realize why
people historically were really
interested in this because they were
like it doesn't look like it should be
that hard there are only seven places
you have to go across but no one could
come up with a solution right and
everyone wondered is it just that
there's like a complicated solution we
just haven't thought of yet or maybe as
some of you may be assigned to think
because I saw how many of you were
getting your rubbers out and give me to
go
maybe this can't be done maybe it's
impossible okay now what we're gonna do
is try and unpack what is going on here
and I'm gonna do that by connecting it
to the topic that we're in right now and
explaining like why do we care about
this problem okay so I'm gonna give you
three reasons and I'd love you if you
have they're heading already the bridges
of königsberg maybe you want to make
this as a subheading because I think
it's important not just to know how to
do stuff you're gonna work out how to do
this in a minute but also know why
you're doing it like for me that's the
main motivator right so I'm gonna give
you three reasons the first one's a
history reason I asked you before about
how many of you said in history so I
studied more history when I was at
school and I'm basically this single
problem this single problem is why we
invented networks or in fact as they
called it back then and as it's like
called at university and we call this
graph theory right so this whole topic
in many ways like the fact that you guys
are studying this in the course the
whole reason that networks exists is
like a field that we study is because of
this problem this is where it all began
this is like the granddaddy of all the
problems you've ever had to encounter in
the topic in the course so far and you
will continue to encounter so for a
historical reason right
the second reason is once we unpack this
once we work out what this has to do
with our topic we actually gain some
further insight into the way these
networks function together as you'll
soon discover this network is actually
kind of a special network and we'll work
out why it's special and
trying to solve this problem and realize
in this review part is how we gain that
insane okay it's one last reason or one
last one that I thought of there are a
ton of practical applications and that's
the way most of the things in this
course ah I'll just give you two real
quick ones right when when the garbage
gets collected every week right the
trucks have to go across all of the
different houses they've got to get
through and I want to do that
efficiently right that's a problem very
much like this one can you think about
how it's similar
it's like cross every bridge get to
every house as it were right so I know
that seems like a really boring kind of
thing to do but we kind of rely on this
every single day
right now garbage collection is of
course about picking things up taking
away from houses what's the opposite of
that who in our society does the
opposite of taking things away from
houses yeah the mail thank you very much
so the postal system right the postal
system might not have to get to every
single house every single week but
they'll get like ah you've got to drop
off packages at these 20 places right
and all seven places it's like I want to
make sure that you get to all of these
and I don't double back that's like a
waste of time and money and I'm fuel and
all that kind of thing okay so here's
what we're gonna do this time rather
than going on your piece of paper you
want to go and do this in your book if
you haven't already so what I'm going to
do is we're going to take this and we're
going to represent this using the same
kind of network diagrams that we've been
using all the way through this topic
okay
now there are seven bridges right seven
bridges these bridges join together
other kinds of things right so what kind
of objects you let a lot of words in
terminology earlier on in this topic
what kinds of objects been that bridges
connect other things what do you think
these bridges should be represented as
in our diagram yeah
these should be edges right between one
of the things that are joined by edges
we call them vertices right so there are
going to be some vertices on here and
the bridges are gonna be our edges
between them okay so I'm gonna just
shuffle back here so that I don't get in
the way if you guys seen this right so
now this is actually a tricky question
I'm gonna ask you guys before I show you
the answer I'm gonna ask you we know
that there are seven bridges so there
are going to be seven edges I want you
to think for a minute on your own how
many vertices do
you think we can use to draw this
diagram right we could draw lots and
lots I mean we could draw like one for
every building if we wanted to clearly
we want to have fewer rather than more
can I give you a minute to actually see
where might you put vertices go and try
it on your own piece of paper and then
where would you connect them let me give
you some time to do that first